maybe I can make myself clear
I want a title shot
damn right
I don't know what you think but it don't
work like that feeling so cold what it
got to lose what you got to lose what
you think I could just snap my fingers
and make you a contender overnight ain't
that what happened to you
it's like this bro
I respect you
but my clock ticking it's not enough for
me
and I want to help you like I said I
would
man what you asking me is
it's kind of impossible
you don't know what it's like bro
go ahead Tom and him
them walls
impossible
they take your name
they give you a number
that's how it started
what was the best though
yeah you were
I was broke
but I never got a chance to prove that
look all I'm saying bro
Apollo Creed
could take a chance on some Underdog
why can't you
sleep okay
how's the rest last night
what's good yeah he's catching up
hey why didn't you ever tell me about
the group home
wasn't a lot to say
how old are you
surrounded Mars age
you don't want to talk about it
no it's okay
now it's a day
you know you asked me to fight Felix
for real yeah heavyweight champion of
the world and he wants a shot
so what'd you say
no
it was impossible you know
people with their whole lives for a shot
like that and he's not even a pro yeah
yeah why does it look like you're still
considering
all right all right
stay in front of them baby cut off that
ring
[Music]
that's right
look at me man you and your own and now
let's go let's go let's go
keep fighting let's go let's go
okay
okay baby come on come on come on come
on
let's go Grandpa
stay focused Jazz Jabs give it to me
work yourself
hey what's going on out here
that was intentional you handle this
are you talking what happened are you
doing my job hey come here man
leave all that other mess outside
I told you who I wanted
and I told you it's going to take some
time all right
take a walk
it's a man
hey Adonis hey dude this was a mistake I
told you right away it was a mistake I
got it you don't
you let him come in here with a chip on
his shoulder that's exactly but don't
get quiet now dookie man it's okay it's
okay it's okay relax I know I got you I
got I know I know just let it go okay
I got under control
just telling you who he is right
believe him